what do you think about robot police no
no no no no
yeah and the only reason i say that is
because who are who's controlling them
i don't know what if it's a
decentralized algorithm that we're all
aware of nah
you could be like show me your code and
it will be like z and you'll see like
it's orders and everything but then you
got like who wrote the code
and can it get hacked it's not just that
you got you got a homeless veteran with
no legs
and he's he's he's smoking a joint under
a bridge with no one around
and the robot drone comes down and goes
violation section two three a
marijuana use in public you are under
arrest and the guys
like a regular cops get back i don't
care about you so bad laws the cop uses
his common sense and is like i'm not
gonna prosecute a bad law right now well
well you know i think that it'll work
but it'll get out of control
so you can you know the little drone i
mean it just depends you know somebody
just shoot the thing out the air and now
it's a
bigger deal but you throw a roll of
toilet paper at it yeah yeah you throw
water
but if it was like a terminator but if
it was something that could actually
catch people in crimes and
it'll stick around until the cops can
get there or whatever
yeah i mean that could work but it could
that's then you get
more manipulation you're like well how
far will this thing go and what are they
going to do in the next 10 years
are they going to make physical cops
that didn't
use force against you you know and then
they get out of control
and then whoever's controlling them now
they make a law
and they use use of force policy for you
know you can't a machine won't go to
jail
so once they beat the crap out of you
it's not nothing going to happen and
it's pros and cons
so if you jaywalk a cop can be like i
don't care if he's just walking
or he can be like oh that's jaywalking
you're going to take it robot every
single time will be like warning
jaywalker spotted and it's going to stop
they could make the robot have
discretion
i mean as smart as ai is today they can
make robots have discretion
i don't think they could i i physically
could but not legally i think it would
be too many lawsuits
well it depends i mean honestly just
walking around with a body camera that's
on 24 hours a day and monitoring all
these behaviors
it could say it could prioritize certain
things because
in any given intersection you can have a
jaywalker and then somebody
speeding any given intersection you have
a jaywalker and you have somebody else
doing something else more egregious or
you can have a person who's jaywalking
and it's not a threat or a person who's
jaywalking across the green you know
you're walking across a green light
um and so there could be prioritized i
mean they can do whatever they want to
do with these computers
but i think it gets out of control i i
the government is not our friend
so you think it's easier to get corrupt
cops under control they're like buddy
buddy and won't turn each other in than
it is to get keep robots under control
yeah 100
100 because most cops don't like these
bad cops
like we had some in my department they
got fired but nobody liked them
it was this one guy and i won't say his
name he's always pushed the limit
push the envelope you're supposed to
identify where you go every time you get
on the radio
you know 2 out of 117 that was my call
sign 12 117 i'm checking out here with
one at
these cross streets he would not check
out
and just be doing some rogue stuff but
it wasn't against the law
skirting against policy but then he
he does things that lead to other things
that ended up getting himself fired
because
he started cheating on different things
and manipulate numbers
but we everybody hated him he used to
ask me to go on calls with him like i
only want to go on a call with you
because you're going gonna get us in a
position where i'm gonna have to fight
somebody or whatever the case may be
we hated him thank god he was off the
police department when he got fired
everybody celebrated
there's officers on the police
department that are like that and
i'll tell you one unfortunate thing that
you won't hear people say if they're
unless they want to be completely honest
is that there are cops that cops don't
like
and they are bad cops but they're not
breaking the law
right you know there's two cops that i
can think of right now that if you
resist the rest
they're going to work you they're going
they're going to tune you up
and nickel rides huh yeah nick arrives
yeah yeah
they'll tune you up and so is it legal
yeah if you throw a punch at a police
officer they can fight you back
but they're going to tune you up no
mercy if you pull a gun on somebody or
you you pull out a knife on somebody
i know god will shoot you and kill you
and won't even care about it probably a
laugh at it
after a while is that illegal no i don't
think it's right
but it's not gonna get you fired um
and those things do occur so when people
say that
cops do stuff excessive force and things
it's like i can see that happening
but we can work together we can we can
we can work to er you know get rid of
people
on the police department like that we
can work for transparency i i
i have my you know likes and dislikes
about body worn cameras
but bodywork cameras overall in totality
circumstances is a good thing
we can do more things like that on the
police department and and make things uh
better and more transparent that's fine
but defunding the police
acting like every police shooting is a
is a bad
shoot like you're never going to get
anywhere with that well let me ask you
then so
so to the point about robot cops and
another point one that needs to be
brought up is bad laws in the
constitution
so right now i mean i can talk about the
rigidity of a robot cop but the
constitution says shall not be infringed
cops in new york city don't care cops in
new jersey don't care they don't care
what the constitution
says didn't you swear an oath the
constitution police yeah the
constitution should come before any laws
so then how could how could you be you
know uh
in new jersey with this one story a
woman was from philadelphia
legally allowed to own a gun and she was
like mid-40s and she jumped the bridge
you know just like like drove across the
bridge it's a five minute drive you want
to go to casino
she gets pulled over cop without
question arrests are charged with a
felony
for gun possession she's she has a
concealed carry permit from her state
she made a mistake she was just stupid
felony charge
yeah you could charge a person with that
but i don't think that's going to go far
in court
it ended up so for political reasons
this this one particular case ended up
getting stopped but
look man in chicago you got a lot of
people
who are just a dad in a family and he's
like i know what they call this place
shy wreck so i'm buying a gun i don't
care what the law says i have a right to
defend myself
yeah these people get felony charges i
know that's i i i'm like you on
it's we need to fix these things because
the constitution should trump any gun
laws
but it's the cops man it's not the cops
it's the legislators that we elect
that create the laws and cause us to
enforce it because
cops don't make the laws cops don't even
want to enforce these laws
but you have sworn to uphold the
constitution and the laws
so how do you do both so what's
constitutionally acceptable right the
constitution we have votes people vote
on legislators and legislators pass laws
and so when they pass a law
just because just case you just because
you don't like it or maybe you feel that
it's
slightly infringing on your
constitutional rights don't mean
that the police shouldn't enforce them
like for instance voter laws
some people believe it's an infringement
on the constitutional right that they
have to show identification to vote
i don't well that should enforce that so
the difference i suppose is you've got i
think what are the what are they the the
14th
19th um and the 26th amendments i think
pertain to i could be in the numbers
wrong pertain to voting
and so voting isn't as clearly defined
in the constitution
about what you're guaranteed there are
some things where you can't be
restricted based on certain
characteristics as the amendments i
mentioned like sex race etc
but when it comes to second amendment
the right to keep and bear arms shall
not be infringed
is it is it infringing on someone's
right to bear arms telling them they
literally can't have a gun in public
well i i think yes but also people vote
for those laws
in the state of arizona we're
constitutional characters my rights
aren't up for a vote no it's what i'm
saying but i'm saying like we put it in
michael malus by the way
yeah we'll put it in the totality of
circumstances we'll say in the state of
arizona constitutional carry we don't
need permits we carry everywhere conceal
whatever
and it doesn't matter now one day the
public
in a democracy you know that we claim we
live in
people can vote that there can be
additive laws to restrict
gun possession in certain cases like
convicted felons
different things like that we
arbitrarily vote
for laws that thwart our constitutional
rights
to a certain degree and we vote for that
and not not
everybody because some people don't
agree with it but some people do
just like you know that's what the
constitution's for man i know i know and
i think that's why you have case law and
you have other things that are brought
to the supreme court to
give guidance on how to to float with
this because i guarantee you a person
who
has a concealed carry permit and they
cross state lines
prosecuting them is going to be almost
impossible i can't see a person getting
prosecuted for felony charge if if
they're not
malice if there's no malicious intent
bro it happens i know it happens but
it's very it's very
it's very rare unless there's
culpability there like somebody
intentionally saying
i'm going to break the law that i know
is present in this state i'm across
state lines break the law get caught
doing something else with this gun
and you give prosecution more there was
a story about an old lady who was in her
60s and she was from i think like
kentucky
and she had a legal permit for a
revolver she went to visit chicago to
see the sites
and she went to some tourism spot where
she informed security like oh before i
go and i want to let you know i have my
my concealed carry with me and they're
like right right this way ma'am
felony charge she went to prison i knew
a guy
is that the full story though i mean
that's full story old lady had no idea
what's going on and they put her in
prison dude illinois is
crazy man yeah i don't know there was a
dude there was a there was a dude in
illinois
who uh his family was house-sitting for
their neighbors
and the local cops knew the neighbors
were out of town
this kid was eight he was 18 a kid he's
a man now and
he went to the neighbor's house took one
of their beers and started drinking it
the cops drove by and saw through the
window that the kid was drinking beer
and they knew the family's out of town
so they went in and arrested him and
then when it turns out he said
i was my family's house sitting for the
neighbors they wanted us to be checking
on their house
they were like did you enter the house
did you take property
mandatory minimum send them to prison no
these stories happen man i gotta i got
now i
i believe you i trust you in good faith
i have to read
and listen to a court document of
some of some judge sentencing somebody
or even a prosecution's argument beyond
a reasonable doubt that this person is
guilty of this this story was really
controversial
sorry but like i'm gonna look it up man
because that's because there's
there's mandatory mandatory minimum laws
and so the judge's response was
the law is the law i have to sentence
someone who enters the property of
another person and takes property it's
burglary
end of story and apparently like the
prison was was like we
they wouldn't it was like ingestion or
whatever like when they were like we're
not gonna fight this paper this is
ridiculous it's insane
we're over yeah inside like we're
overcrowded as it is and this kid who
took a beer
and there was like some big controversy
about it yeah i gotta watch that man
because i'm like okay a kid and then it
could be in a totally long time
there could stuff goes wrong in the
court of law
more frequently than people expect but
not as much as people want it to be
um but that's very interesting that they
would be able to
to get a person on that and then have a
complainant i mean you gotta have the
people who own the house have to be
victim
victims of this no the cops witnessed
the crime in progress
and they get the and so the police were
the witnesses who said
we witnessed a crime yeah that's
interesting because police can't
necessarily be independent witnesses of
a crime you have to have a victim
you can't just say oh a guy stole a beer
how do you know if that person
stole the beer or the store or let them
have the beer so police have to have
their independent operator they cannot
prosecute people
you can be a you could be a witness to a
crime to a certain degree but you have
to have
a victim of a crime to us you know yeah
i'll stress this point too
yeah these are really old stories from
back when i was growing up in in chicago
and
as we learned with like george floyd you
always learned there was something else
that didn't tell you about but i knew
this one guy too
and again this guy this is someone i
knew personally he may have lied to me
he was from
uh l.a he was driving to uh he was
driving to the east coast and he had
guns
legal guns he drove through illinois
now you got the federal law protecting
your right to drive you know
to move yeah cops didn't care so he
ended up
being forced to live in illinois for
like four years because of the gun
charges
but i'm wondering what so they pulled
him over so basically they pulled him
over at some point
yes or something so my understanding of
what happens is he's driving from
la somewhere on the east coast and he
gets off the highway
to go do something and that's when they
were like ah if you were moving
and just passing through you had been on
the highway by getting off the highway
you're now in state jurisdiction
you're in illegal possession of firearms
yeah i
i'm not saying this wrong or right but
these cases send them to me man i would
love to review it
i'll i'll tell you it's like maybe i'm
biased because i've dealt with some of
this stuff
yeah so i i was uh i was driving on
lakeshore drive in chicago i'm i'm
exiting at belmont
i'm about 10 miles under the limit
because i'm getting off on an exit
and i get pulled over cop walks up to me
and says you were speeding
phil's out of ticket says sign this and
i was like whoa i wasn't speeding i was
i was 10 under i'm exiting i'm on the
exit and he's like tell it to a judge
you can sign this or i can arrest you
so i signed the ticket okay i guess i
forget about it
i went to visit my sister because my
brother-in-law was stationed in iraq and
she was
you know suffering from anxiety just
like you know and so i'm like okay i'll
you know i want to get out of the city
i'll go i'll go to colorado
once i came back two months later i got
pulled over
and the cop walks up he pulls me over he
walks into the window and goes are you
tim pool and i was like yes and he goes
out of the vehicle you're under arrest
for driving on suspended license
and i was like what and he was like
driving a suspended license fills it out
this is where i got i bonded he was like
if someone can come and pick up your
vehicle and drive you home i won't take
you to the station but you have a court
date for
you know where they say it was a class a
misdemeanor up to one year in jail and a
2
500 fine for driving on a suspended
license when i went to
court and i talked to the prosecutor and
i was just like i'm really sorry
it happened i was in colorado i was on i
was in fort use i think it's uh
not for you uh um cars fort carson
that's right i was at fort carson
visiting my sister my brother-in-law is
in iraq you know iraq and so
but i just gotten back and i was
literally back from colorado
a you know a mile from my house and he
went oh so you confess
no joke he's like oh you confessed to
driving on a suspended license and i was
like
uh well i'm just trying to let you know
like i didn't get any notification he's
like ignorance of the laws and excuse
for breaking it
so if you want to plead guilty we can
talk about what your sentence is going
to be
and so then i was like okay i'll plead
guilty and he was like
i'll tell you this we'll give you a 100
fine court supervision if you plead
guilty right now and i was like okay
and then when i went up in front of the
judge he said
how do you plead and i said guilty your
honor and he goes and
you know do you state for the record or
whatever that you were in no way coerced
to make this plea and i said
no i was coerced your honor and he went
excuse me and i was like i i was coerced
to plead guilty
so what are you talking about and i was
like he told me that if i didn't plead
guilty i'd go to jail for a year
and then the judge was like come back in
a month and get a lawyer
every lawyer i got said it doesn't
matter if there was a reasonable reason
why
you were driving it doesn't matter if
there's a sympathetic reason it doesn't
matter that you didn't actually break
the law in the first place
my license got suspended because if you
get two tickets under the age of 21 they
suspend your license for three months
i wasn't speeding the cop gave me a bunk
ticket anyway i had no means to fight
that ticket because i was a bro i think
i was like 19 or something
i was no i think i was yeah i was 19. i
had no way to fight it so i was just
like i don't know
and then i forgot about it and then
after a certain amount of time it went
into
uh i forgot what they call it where it's
it becomes a guilty plea if you don't
respond
and i had no idea i had no way to pay
for a 75
ticket and i didn't know that as soon as
you pay for it you pleading guilty
otherwise i would have contested it so
i'm gone for two months right before i
get a chance to go home before i got any
mail new anything was happening they
said you broke the law by driving
then they tried to they threatened me
with a year in jail that's kind of stuff
i'm you know so
you you were guilty i mean exactly you
got to say you were guilty
you were at fault you were wrong now
there's great
there's now hold on a second i was
legally guilty
but i did nothing wrong so but but but
i'll say this and i agree i agree with
you but at the same time
this is why i want to empower young
people to
to know how to fight these things when
they feel like they've been done wrong
because if you were not speeding you
have a right to fight that you don't
need it you don't need a lawyer i got
illegally pulled over
i don't i only learned that right after
the fact you don't have to you don't
need a lawyer
all you gotta do is go to court and the
state has the burden or
it's not necessarily the same as a
criminal charge but
the preponderance of evidence is going
to be on them they have to show
proponents of evidence to cite you on a
citation like that
so you should go to court and say i was
not speeding
i was on the off ramp this is what i was
doing the officer pulled me over
and and but it's also things you could
ask the police officer that if he didn't
say he he screws himself like how did he
track your speed
was he doing a radar was he pacing you
or was he
um somehow doing a visual estimate well
so so
in this instance the after i think it
was like three months
there was a deadline to pay the ticket
and my sister paid it for me and that
was a guilty plea
it didn't matter at that point and i
didn't know about the suspension law
they said ignorance was no excuse for
breaking it but i also didn't realize
that by saying okay i'll give you the
money you've asked for
i was effectively going to be committed
to crime by trying to go home
but here's the here's the thing i
realized after the fact when i was back
i was in glen ellen illinois
when i was back it was like late at
night like midnight or two in the
morning
the cop who pulled me over pulled me
over illegally what he did was he ran my
plates
saw my name registered to the car saw
that my name was associated with a
suspended license
and that was just his grounds for
pulling someone over but that's actually
not a legal stop
because what if someone else was driving
the car he didn't have justification for
stopping the car in the first place
right that could be true
that could be true depending on the
state and also depending on what he can
articulate right
if he yeah if he sees you if you know
but if you see your driver's license if
you see your driver's license they have
a picture of mbd driver license and the
person in the vehicle look like you
it's very similar to you similar
characteristics he can conduct an
investigative
investigative stop meaning that he has
reason to believe that you are temple
driving he see you he believed that
you're the same person that matched the
driver's license
some states prohibit this but but some
states allow it as an investigative stop
he could pull you over and you've
confessed i am temple okay well my
investigative stop was that i thought it
was you
you agreed that it was you and now
you're driving on suspended license i've
found this is true this is the problem
uh so my understanding after the fact
was that he needed a legitimate reason
it's like i ended up talking to lawyers
or whatever that
you can't just assume somebody is
driving a car because there's a lot of
people who could look like a lot of
people and
you know i guess chicagoland has issues
with this kind of stuff but
ultimately my my complaint is look i get
it yeah i was i i broke the law that's a
fact
yeah but we can't have the rigidity and
like the system can't be this rigid
where it punishes young people
for silly things like this and to have
like some
some 40 year old guy look me in the eye
and say i'm gonna put you in jail for
one year unless you do what you're told
and i'm like bro like is there no
consideration for the humanity in any of
these circumstances
yeah i think there is no i think it's
the empowerment of the people right
um it's our fault to a certain degree
that we don't if we don't know the laws
it's our fault that we don't know
because because to be honest we can all
look this up for cop
this is why i think it's important to
empower people to know this because some
people don't know they can't do this
you can look up these laws and read them
yourself if you go and get put over by a
police officer and you say well what are
my charges and they give you a charge
they write them down
you can go and google in the state law
whatever or municipality
you can google the law and read the
statute and it says very clearly this
statute has to be met
and if they don't you're like okay i can
defend myself in court
your honor according to this statute
subsection so and so did
this and this i was not committing this
he pulled me over illegally
the state has to the preponderance of
evidence to prove he has to
prove more than 51 of the evidence that
no he was right
in this instance the problem i have is
at no point
are you informed by anyone that if you
get two moving violations under the age
of 21 they suspend your license
it should they should inform you when
you're when you get your driver's
license
they don't you should you should because
then you have to go through and look at
the laws the driving
laws you should review them and
hopefully on your driver's license you
confirm that you have reviewed and
understood the laws
that are on the books by admitting to or
accepting a driver's license you are
accepting a responsibility that you are
aware
of all the driving laws and you maintain
a concurrent knowledge
or an ongoing knowledge of the laws and
if you don't it's
we need to be empowered because if we're
not in power then we believe that
it's an excuse to not know the laws and
the judge is like
i don't care like why don't you look it
up i don't have to babysit you and let
you know
you should look it up and know the laws
yourself or you can hire a lawyer
or you can you know so it's definitely
difficult
but we need to be empowered and take our
position back of saying
i don't have to default to a lawyer um
if i just read the statute unless it's
complicated
i think the system needs the system
itself needs to default more to a
libertarian stance of
all right we understand what happened in
this regard don't do it again most of
the time it's like that
i i i i would get furious
at judges because they they give people
too many passes
um now i'm talking about a traffic
ticket that's that's whack you know we
would go to the court and people would
lose those tickets and they just pay a
fine and it's fine
or sometimes they win they go up i find
that there's not a proponent of evidence
or whatever by the state
you you know you're not guilty or
whatever you not
not responsible not guilty is a criminal
charge but
when i would go to court you're talking
about going to court
they would let people off all the time i
had a guy arrested him four times
black kid i risked him four times in in
a matter of like a week
one was a felony charge of four felony
crimes trafficking stolen property and a
whole bunch of other stuff
we i had a 20-minute conversation with
him coming to jesus conversation with
him
he goes to jail i'm thinking that he's
going to least stay in there for a night
the next day we get a call for service
of a person pulling on doorknobs
he's trying to get into vacant houses i
recognize him
i say hey man and i'm just going to talk
to him he gets spooked he runs he almost
dies
running in the middle of the street he
goes on a chase i had to chase him down
we ran through somebody's house through
the house
jumped back yards he had all kinds of
felony crimes he could have been charged
with
um and this is another story of why the
lady didn't prosecute and this is the
dumbest thing ever and i have to mention
it but i'll go
past that long story short five
misdemeanor crimes
that he committed that day which is
after he committed felony crimes he goes
to court again
like uh two or three days later i catch
him at a in
somebody's vacant house i didn't know it
was him as a bunch of kids i go and i'm
recognizing
see him in there run his name he has a
domestic violence warrant after his
arrest because he beat up his aunt and
then knocked her windows out of their
house
so now i've arrested him three times for
felony charges violent charges
he's fleeing the police and he
i think it was two weeks later or a
month later i saw him out on a jail at a
bus stop
it's like how on god's green earth
do you commit that many crimes and you
and some of them are violent domestic
violence and you don't even you don't
even do a week in jail i mean maybe a
month in jail problem goes both ways man
that's
that's it some people are given a free
pass and some people are given the book
you know what i mean yeah and
i think that more people get passes than
the book people just don't
think so give you an example my family
member 70 years in prison
how did he get 70 years in prison he
shot two three people
and he was in possession of illegal
drugs because i had looked up his
charges and he was a prohibited
possessor he was already convicted felon
so he shouldn't had a gun he shot three
people and he was possession of of a
dangerous substance they gave him 70
years
how many years do you think he did or
he's going to do
20. how many say 20 15
15. they're gonna give him 15 he'd be
out of pro oh i got it
yeah 15. 15 years he'd be on parole
which is a good game
is right you know like without going but
70 versus 15
oh think about the people he shot he
probably like i hope he'd go to
i hope he goes i don't like the idea
that we just say like lock em away for a
long time i think the idea is like we
gotta we gotta help this person
you know what i mean like i think so too
maybe maybe not if you're you're dealing
with kids
you probably should go to prison for the
rest of your life or you or you have
legitimately rape the woman with force
you should you should go to jail until
she feels comfortable with you being out
of jail that's what i think
different crimes some crimes lock them
up throw away the keys i support
execution i'm just afraid of
executing the wrong people but same with
throwing the wrong people away for a
lifetime right too
but you know like you said some people
get the bad end of the stick some people
um you know they they they had appeals
they were guilty yeah they had
opportunities at fair trial
they lost man it's over look for for all
the problems
a lot of people don't realize we got a
pretty good system well the problem i
mean the big name a better one
every human every law like the
the the flaw in the system that i'm
getting is every human should read every
law and understand
every law federal and state and local
and then tomorrow make sure you re-read
everything or at least acknowledge all
the changes made to every law
so you know every law at every moment
and if you don't
that's a problem even the people that
sign the laws
in the into law in congress don't read
the bill sometimes before they sign it
or vote on it see that's a huge flaw in
the system that we're going to need to
address but i don't think you have to
know out of laws just like you don't
have to
know all the real estate laws or
whatever case it be because then you
have you have access to counsel
so people who are experts in it you just
need to know the functional laws like
maybe if you're going to speed just know
the speeding laws you know if you're
going to be operating a motor vehicle
and you know whatever you need to know
how to function the vehicle know the
turns
no make basic laws if you're going to be
murdering people then you need to know
the murder laws but if you're not
murdering nobody you don't need to know
laws around murder
or laws around aggravated assault or
domestic violence or if you're not going
to be doing those things
but you can always read these laws and
be informed
as things pop up i think it's invaluable
for people to watch these cases that go
on
in the court of law i used to watch
court tv all the time even when i was a
cop
because you learn a lot like the george
floyd trial people should be watching it
not only to pick a side but to learn how
the court system works so when you mess
around and be in court
hopefully not for murder but when you go
to court you will understand
the value of defense and the value of
functionality
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 p.m where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time